when I was a kid I could find Wonder
pretty much anywhere I looked I could
just turn over a stone in the garden and
be amazed by everything that was
underneath it back then you'd run and
tell all your friends if you found a
ladybug or a four-leaf clover hidden in
the grass and when you saw the first
Firefly of the summer it was a real
event
but over time I guess I've just seen a
lot of ladybugs in my backyard and it
seems like I traveled farther and
farther away to find that feeling of
wonder sometimes it just feels like
there isn't all that much wonder left
here at home but maybe that's the
challenge to find wonder right where you
are about 15 miles from me in watts Los
Angeles there's a tower that looks like
a madman's jungle gym in the middle of a
residential neighborhood in the 1920s an
Italian immigrant named Simon Rodia
built it as his home he built the whole
thing by himself using rebar and coat
hangers and cement local kids would
bring him bottle caps and seashells and
broken bits of pottery that he used to
decorate it that's one way to do it just
build wonder right where you are maybe
as you get older the stones you have to
overturn or less about finding something
new and more about revealing the history
of the thing hidden away in downtown Los
Angeles you can still ride on something
called the angels flight in 1901 it was
the shortest train ride in the world
which is a strange record to hold you
paid one penny in your road for one
minute but even some of the more
spectacular things get richer with a bit
of history up above the city the
Griffith Observatory is pretty awesome
by itself come on it's got a giant
telescope in it what's not to love but
it's also where the Apollo astronauts
learned how to navigate the Stars
imagine that looking up and trying to
memorize where everything was because
you're about to go there they still have
the chair that those astronauts sat in
maybe that's just it
trying to find a chair to experience a
place through someone else's eyes so
what about where you live what are the
stories of wonder in your hometown that
you still have to discover it might take
a little effort but it's amazing when
you find it when you find wonder again